la tension ne retombe pas entre athènes
et ankara
malgré les appels à la désescalade des
manoeuvres militaires rivales ont eu
lieu ce mercredi en méditerranée
orientale
d'un côté des navires de guerre turcs
ont procédé à des exercices avec un
destroyer américain selon le ministre
turc de la défense de l'autre son
homologue grec a annoncé un exercice
militaire conjoint avec chypre l'italie
et la france en méditerranée orientale
la zone disputée en dépit des appels au
calme de l'europe
l'otan et les états unis le président
turc campe sur ses positions
la turquie en méditerranée en mer egée
en mer noire obtiendra ce qui lui
revient
de la même manière que nous n'avons pas
les yeux sur le territoire la
souveraineté les intérêts d'autres ne
feront absolument aucune concession sur
ce qui nous appartient nous invitons nos
homologues à se ressaisir et à se garder
de toute erreur qui ouvrirait la voie à
leur ruine
en réponse au président turc le premier
ministre grec a consolidé la position de
son pays ce mercredi en lançant devant
les députés grecs la future extension de
la zone côtière grecque
j'annonce aujourd'hui à la
représentation nationale que la grèce
avec un projet de loi qui sera soumis
par le gouvernement étendra la zone
côtière à l'ouest de 6 à 12 milles
nautiques
[Musique]
un différend maritime qui oppose les
deux pays depuis des décennies et qui
s'est amplifiée ces dernières semaines
en cause la recherche d'hydrocarbures en
méditerranée orientale se positionnant
médiateur la ministre allemande de la
défense a fustigé ce mercredi les
manoeuvres militaires rivales
estimant qu'elle n'était pas à la
désescalade entre la turquie et la grèce
ce que nous devons trouver c'est un
point de départ pour nous permettre
d'entrer à nouveau dans des discussions
et des négociations politiques
les manoeuvres qui ont pris place
aujourd'hui ne nous est certainement pas
nous sommes totalement d'accord là
dessus
de son côté paris averti la méditerranée
orientale ne doit pas être je cite un
terrain de jeu des ambitions de certains